Remember back in school,...
...when you either invited the new kid over to your table or you didn't?
If you did, that was a cool move.
That was an "and" move.
"And" moves take guts, but they can mean everything.
Their "and" move was to put wings on a bicycle.
Now, we fly.
When enough people have an "and" view, the world changes forever.
If you think about it, you're only here because of an "and" moment.
Opening yourself up isn't easy, but when you do, it's hard to forget...
...because it leads to something new, something better.
That's why we need this and this and them and you.
Yeah, you, watching this right now.
Because everyone doing the same thing won't move us forward,...
...but everyone doing their own thing, together, can.